while the live-action mulan contains
plenty for both kids and adults to enjoy
some elements of the film will only be
noticed by adults
from symbolic imagery to systemic
societal issues
here are some of the things only adults
notice in mulan
as mulan prepares to meet with the
village matchmaker her mother helps her
get dressed and paints her face
during this getting ready sequence we
see a number of laces and ribbons being
tied tight as mulan grimaces
showing clearly how constricting she
finds not only the clothing
but the entire affair when she emerges
she comments to her sister that the
getup completely prevents her from
expressing herself
this is my sad face this is my curious
face
and i'm confused
this isn't the only time that binding
imagery is used to convey mulan having
to suppress who she really is
most notably she has to bind her chest
in order to pass as a male
soldier later the removal of those
bindings helps symbolize the death of
her male alter ego
quajoon and the emergence of hua mulan
as her true self once she embraces her
identity
she undoes the bindings of her armor and
hair ties kids will pick up on the idea
that mulan is shedding a false sense of
who she was supposed to be
but adults are more likely to notice
that binding has been a recurring theme
since the very beginning of the movie
symbolizing not just mulan's internal
struggle but the external pressures of
what society determines
women should be mulan also makes
frequent use of
shadows reflections and other ways of
showing characters indirectly to
illustrate how they struggle with
identity
many of these devices factor prominently
into how shenyang is portrayed
in showing mulan's journey to becoming a
self-actualized warrior
for shanyang whose life has taught her
that her choices are either hide who she
is
or be shunned by society we frequently
see her through smoke and shadows
meanwhile mulan is often shown in
reflections which highlights the
incongruity between the person she feels
she is on the inside
and the image she has to project on the
outside for much of the film
when mulan looks at herself her
reflection wars with her own perception
of who she is
the choice to frequently portray the
film's two most powerful female
characters through indirect means helps
convey their internal struggles with
self-image
and their fears of showing the world who
they truly are
kids probably won't think to question
mulan's unswerving devotion to the
emperor and his dynasty
but adult viewers may wonder if mulan's
cause is quite as just as she believes
after mulan is banished from her
regiment shenyang tries to explain to
her that the society
in which they live has no room for
powerful women like them
together she hopes she and mulan may be
able to create a new society that won't
reject them
however mulan doesn't even seem to
consider what chang young is saying
and she rushes off to save the emperor
from bori khan's attack
as a matter of fact mulan never once
seems to interrogate the idea of what
unquestioning fealty to the current
system means for people like her
even though she previously felt stifled
by that very system
the emperor seems like a nice enough guy
but it wouldn't be unreasonable to
wonder whether we should really be
rooting for mulan to safeguard his
dynasty
granted the 1998 film also never
questions the governmental structure
mulan vows to uphold
but in 2020 it seems like a little
healthy introspection may have been both
warranted
and welcome as it stands it seems a
little alarming that mulan fights so
hard to maintain a status quo that
grants tremendous power to men of a
certain bloodline
while keeping women as a subservient
class
while mulan makes friends with all her
fellow soldiers adults won't be able to
miss that the looks hung wei
is giving hua jun contained far more
than brotherly affection
fans who interpreted lee shang as
bisexual in the 1998 film will likely
pick up on the same energy in hong wei
although it's possible hong wei
suspected that mulan was female all
along
the simpler explanation is that hong wei
was simply attracted to huajin
his demeanor toward mulan remains much
the same after her true identity is
revealed
implying that his attraction was never
tied to her gender
it remained constant whether she was
mulan contains a number of impressive
battle sequences
but none of the foes mulan faces loom
nearly as large as the sexism she
encounters in every facet of life
whether she's trying to bring honor to
her family through an arranged marriage
or bring honor to her country through
her skilled fighting as a soldier
she's constantly butting up against the
societal constraints placed upon women
she's told that her powerful qi is a
liability for a woman
although it would be an asset for a man
and during training women are forbidden
from entering the soldiers camp bringing
women into camp
or consorting with women in any way
penalty
death what's more this same sexist
depression is what drove sean young to
side with bori khan in the first place
she tells mulan that she tried to find a
noble path forward
but it didn't exist within an acceptable
society the only options available to
her were to either ally herself with an
enemy of the kingdom
or deny her own power the more power i
showed the more i was quacked just like
you
considering that xiang young is
instrumental in gaining bori khan most
of his tactical advantages during the
film
it's hard to ignore that if society
hadn't been so intent on oppressing
women
the emperor may not have needed saving
in the first place
throughout the film mulan is constantly
trying to embody the three pillars of
virtue
loyal race
and true
early on she strives to live out these
virtues and make her family proud
through restraining her impulses in
order to present herself well
to make a good and respectable match
later she experiences
a crisis of conscience when she realizes
she can't possibly be true
while also deceiving everyone around her
ultimately she comes into her own when
she rejects both the societal
expectations of women
and the pretense of being a man and
embraces her own unique skills and
identity
it's interesting that for the majority
of the film it seems as though everyone
in mulan's life
including mulan herself assumes that
being true
means to accept her place and to stop
bucking traditions and questioning
cultural norms
you are the daughter
learn your place if mulan had remained a
demure and subservient daughter everyone
would have thought that she was being
true to the role that had been given to
her but by the end of the film
we're shown that what's actually true
for mulan is a past that didn't exist
before she carved it out for herself
while kids will likely embrace the
film's themes of self-acceptance on a
surface level
adults are more equipped to unpack the
complex idea that our understanding of
who we are
and how to live truthfully can evolve
over time
in all the promotional material for
milan it seemed as though
shenyang was going to be the main
antagonist of the film
but by the end of the film chanyung has
seen an alternate version of herself
in mulan she ultimately sacrifices
herself to save the younger woman
kids won't miss shenyang's sacrifice but
what they might
fail to see is that shangyoung was never
really a villain at all
shenyang tells mulan that she joined
forces with bori khan
because he was the only one who provided
a place for her and allowed her to be
who she was
but as we see before their encounter
she's really more of a prisoner than a
lieutenant
now i know i serve you
i am the slave and you would do well to
remember it
while she does bori khan's bidding for
much of the film her true motivation is
to create a society in which she can be
accepted without having to diminish
herself
in mulan she sees the possibility of
that society
and she gives her life to help it come
into being rather than an antagonist
working against the hero
shan young proves herself to be a tragic
figure who was ultimately working toward
the same goals as mulan
by the end of the film mulan has
returned home to her village
seeking to beg her family's forgiveness
for how she left and restore their honor
but when she's reunited with her family
they're not angry with her for leaving
but rather relieved that she finally
came back home
her father then tells her that he
recognizes that she's a warrior
and that he should have seen that all
along considering we've just seen mulan
defeat
bori khan single-handedly and get
recognized by the emperor
this exchange makes complete sense but
what young viewers may not have quite
pieced together
is that hua zhou wouldn't actually know
about her accomplishments in battle yet
as children it's easy to assume that the
characters know whatever we know but as
adults the flow of information becomes a
lot clearer
when her father says he sees that mulan
is a warrior
he didn't come to that revelation
because he'd heard of her great feats in
battle
instead it's because he finally admitted
the truth he'd always known about his
daughter
it turns out that none of mulan's
accomplishments were necessary for her
father to finally see her
he'd known who she was from the
beginning
by the end of mulan it seems like
women's rights have taken a big step
forward with mulan being invited to
serve as an officer in the emperor's
guard
but while mulan herself has come a long
way not much has been done for any of
the other women living alongside her
she returns home to find her sister
excited about her upcoming arranged
marriage with the
other women in her village still in
exactly the same circumstances as when
she left
granted none of the other women in mulan
have given any indication that they want
anything else for their lives but that
could simply be because they never
considered that other options might be
open to them
shenyang the only other woman who wanted
something more than what society was
prepared to offer
is dead by the film's end kids may be
satisfied that mulan herself is able to
finally lead the life that she wants
but adults may wonder how much has
really changed
mulan accepting her commission as an
officer in the emperor's guard is
presented as a happy ending
but mulan likely has an extremely hard
road ahead of her
remember the army that she's going to
join is the same one that earlier
in the film reminded its soldiers that
the presence of a woman in the camp was
punishable by death
although the men who fought beside mulan
against bori khan are ready and willing
to accept her as a warrior
there are plenty of other men in the
emperor's guard who don't know her
personally
they aren't all going to be thrilled at
the idea of admitting a woman to their
ranks much less as a leader
not all men will find it easy to let go
of the way things have always been done
in the past and it's probable that at
least some of mulan's fellow soldiers
could decide to make her life
particularly difficult in order to prove
that women have no place among them
mulan was able to earn the respect of
her peers once before
but that was only after she'd previously
earned it as a man
her new career as the only female
officer in the emperor's guard will no
doubt be a tremendously challenging one
but we are sure she's up to the task
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one